foreign
[Music]
binsberg and a finance professor at the
warden School of the University of
Pennsylvania and I'm Jonathan Burke a
financial professor at The Graduate
School of Business at Stanford
University and this is the all else
equal podcast
welcome back everybody today we're going
to do a special episode because we
thought that there's a recent topic that
really deserves some discussion we've
seen several Banks fail in the last
couple weeks last couple days really and
so we want to do an episode and trying
to understand what banks are for why do
we have Banks and actually go even
deeper and ask the question do banks the
way they exist today still make sense
you know Jewels we should also say that
we had actually planned an episode on
Banking and we're really just moving
this episode up so the issues that we'll
talk about today we had planned to talk
about anyway but I think it's very
topical right now and let me start with
a thought experiment because I think
it's a pretty useful thought experiment
I did say we had a fund an investment
fund and this investment fund made the
following advertisement you could put
your money into the fund the investment
fund fans investment risky Investments
but the body will allow you to take out
your initial investment at any time at
par in other words if you invest a
dollar you're allowed to take out your
initial investment at a dollar if you
don't you earn dividends
but at any time you could take it out at
one dollar how would that investment
fund work would that be a very popular
investment fund let's first be realistic
about what's Happening Here we are
promising to investors that they can
always take their money back at the
initial value which suggests that
there's no risk involved in the
investment that they make at the same
time the investment that they're making
is a very risky one say they put their
money and mortgages that could default
or they put their money in long-term
treasuries or equities or whatever
you're thinking about in terms of risky
Investments it seems pretty much
impossible to me Jonathan it's a all
else equal mistake from an individual
Investor's perspective it seems like
it's close to an Arbitrage look I can't
lose money and if things go well I make
money but obviously in a digital
investor will realize there's only a
limited amount of money in the fund so
if any one investor could take their
money out once enough investor have
taken their money out of the if the fund
loses money wants enough investor to
take their money out there'll be no more
money left and those investors who
haven't taken their money out will find
they've lost everything everybody
understands that so the optional thing
to do is if you think the fund is
underwater you should take your money
out first because if you wait other
investors will have their money out and
then you'll be left with nothing in your
investment so this investment fund has
this very unstable characteristic I just
have to think
this fund itself doesn't even have to
lose money I just have to think there's
a possibility and I'll withdraw my money
because I know that if other people
would throw their money I might be there
for nothing and what you just described
Jonathan is what we call a run and in
many ways the fund we just described has
some Eerie similarities to the way that
banking is done today I wouldn't say
every similarities I would say that's
exactly what a bank is it's close to
what a bank is but there are a few
differences right Banks don't only fund
their Investments with deposits they
also have a little bit of long-term debt
which we call corporate bonds they also
have a little bit of equity where the
owners of the bank also provide some
Capital into the bank but indeed the
majority of the bank is financed with
deposits and they have exactly the
characteristics that you just described
and therefore when people think there's
something wrong with this fund with this
bank they want to be out first and
that's what we call a bank run
what makes this investment vehicle a
terrible idea is the instability it can
easily be the case that in fact all the
Investments are doing very well but a
rumor starts that they're not and that
would be enough for me to withdraw my
money because I would think to myself if
I don't withdraw and other investors do
I will be left with no money and so I
need to jump in first the characteristic
of this fund that you can withdraw your
money at par you can withdraw your money
at the amount you invested creates this
incredibly unstable Fund in general a
far better idea is to say you only can
withdraw your money at the current value
of the fund just like a mutual fund for
sure so that if the Investments that the
fund makes have dropped in value a lot
you can pull your money out but you
proportionally take the loss for the
investment losses that the fund or the
bank is made that would be much better
but to come back to the point you made
earlier which I think is important
particularly in the current day and age
of social media it's never been easier
to start a rumor as it is now that is
widespread and reaches a lot of people
in a very short period of time so in
terms of the instability it's almost a
miracle that we haven't seen more Bank
runs recently I think absolutely it's an
incredibly unstable system and I would
argue A system that is archaic an
assistant that we should not continue so
to come back to what you said earlier
why don't we see runs on Apple why don't
we see runs on PG e why don't we see
runs on Enron we saw that PG e and Enron
went bankrupt but what really happened
was the investors in these companies
just have to come to grips with the fact
that if you invest in Risky things you
may lose money you may in fact lose
everything the key difference is all
investors are treated the same investors
who arrive at the post first are not
treated differently to investors arrive
at the post last and so no investor has
an incentive to run to the post the
problem with the bank is if I come to
the post first I get all my money back
and the guy who comes lost gets none of
his money back when you're invest in
Enron everybody gets the same haircut so
there's no incentive to run on Android
and that instability makes a bank a
pretty stupid way to running an
investment account so now then let's go
a little deeper into if it's such a bad
idea
why do they exist so is maybe an
explanation that in the past there was
no better alternative I think the reason
Banks exist is historical that many like
500 years ago one of the things that was
difficult to verify was trust if you
were going to give somebody your money
and you didn't fully have a you didn't
have a legal system and you didn't have
a lot of trust that person had to give
you a lot of assurances that he wouldn't
just steal your money and one way of
giving that insurance is to tell you
look you could take your money off at
any time and so I think that's the
original reason we have backs but in
today's world we don't need that we have
trusted institutions we don't need to
create an institution without
instability
if an investor can come to you and ask
their money back at any point in time
you can think of that as having a lot of
disciplining effect on the person who
runs the bank because you are going to
be very careful with what you do with
the money you're going to be very
careful in what you invested in because
you know that if people find out that
you're doing things that are not so good
then people can just pull out their
money instantly and then that will be
the end of your bank so this threat of
the Run could actually then be used for
something positive it has a disciplining
effect right that's exactly right Jules
and so I would say that what happened in
the interim is we started to develop
institutions to make other forms of
investment possible for example take an
equity investment when you buy stock in
a company I mean in some sense you would
think how could this ever work you give
the company money and then the company
says in return we'll pay you a dividend
if we feel like it you would think why
would they ever feel like paying me
money and of course the answer is that
you have a board of directors that
represents the equity holders and they
get to decide what the dividend is but
of course the problem with that is the
board of directors might be dominated
while large shareholders and they may
exploit the small shareholders and so
you have a system that develops which
passes laws that limits the ability of
large shareholders to exploit small
shareholders and then the end you have a
system of financing called Equity that
works very well so coming back to the
question is if we want to have a bank
what are the two solutions to create a
bank that would be impervious to bank
drivers what are the two solutions that
could have made a bag that makes sense
well so there are two ways to do it one
is to just say let's match the
risklessness of the deposits that people
put in let's match that with Investments
that are equally riskless meaning that
indeed the bank at any point in time
will be able to pay back the deposits
whenever they need to be this is also
sometimes called narrow banking meaning
we don't have this system where you
promise depositors this full promise of
there's no risk while at the same time
taking a lot of risk with your
Investments instead you simply invest
the money in equally riskless Securities
say short-term treasuries and then the
second solution is you give up on the
idea that prepositions can withdraw
their money at par you say okay the bank
is investing in Risky Securities but if
you want to withdraw your money you have
to withdraw your money at whatever the
value of the bank is we actually have
the system today we call it a mutual
fund when you want to withdraw your
money from a mutual fund you're only
able to withdraw the money at the
current value of the mutual fund so if
you put your money in the mutual fund
and the shares dropping value you get to
withdraw your money at the drop value
and so no shareholder has an incentive
to run on the mutual fund we can even
make it more General we have this system
which is equity financing of any regular
firm you can put your money in but if
you want to pull it out you'll have to
sell it to somebody else at the lower
price if the value of the firm dropped
in value exactly the standard way we
Finance Investments this arcade way of
financing banking is somewhat puzzling
why does it continue I mean why do we
still have Banks one explanation is of
course that people started to convince
themselves that it was important that
the depositors should be reassured that
in fact they could always pull their
money out at par and that to prevent a
run we needed to put different systems
in place that would keep them with their
money in the accounts and one way we did
that was by having the government
provide Insurance under various
different ways in which you can provide
insurance we have what's called FDIC
Insurance federal deposits Insurance you
guarantee a certain amount to the
deposit or say up to 250 000 but there's
another way in which the government is
implicitly guaranteeing things because
we've been talking a lot since the
financial crisis about bailing out Banks
if they are not doing very well so you
could have a system where you could
either say let's have a narrow Bank
where the bank promises there's a risk
investment in their depositors and at
the same time only invests in riskless
investment so that the riskiness is
matched or you could say no keep doing
this keep promising depositors riskless
investment they can pull their money out
of party anytime but keep investing in
Risky Securities and instead we'll have
the government insure it so the
government then ensures the downside
that's a pretty good deal for Bank
Equity holders because the way that
works is if things go badly they're not
on the hook the government pays out and
if things go well they keep the profits
heads I win tells you lose exactly and
that's why I think we see modern banking
the reason we have modern Banks is that
Bankers are heavily subsidized by this
government guarantee and frankly Jules
as a taxpayer I'm sick and tired of
paying for Jamie diamonds private jet
people want to have it both ways on the
one hand they argue without banks making
risky Investments the whole economy
would go down and on the other hand they
say it's very important that we offer
depositors risk-free deposits but the
whole point is that you cannot have
banks with riskless deposits and have
them heavily invest in Risky projects in
the economy without having some sort of
a guarantee system or some sort of
support system and so the question is
how much Merit do these arguments have
is it really the case that if we
wouldn't have Banks make these loans and
make these risky Investments would the
economy really suffer and I think that a
lot of things that you said earlier and
that we discussed earlier already
indicate that maybe it isn't such a big
problem because we've gotten quite used
to the idea that investors put money in
Risky things and take hits when those
risky things don't work they're called
corporate bond contracts they're called
Equity contracts they're called to do
mutual funds to all kinds of vehicles
people today are heavily investing in
Risky projects and taking the hits when
they don't pay off I mean what's so
ironic is that the same people that
claim that these Banks offering
depositors the right to withdraw a poor
and investing in Risky Securities are so
vital to our economy these same people
doubt Silicon Valley and Venture Capital
if the banks were so vital why would
venture capital be used I mean in other
words we have perfect examples of
financing of risky Investments of new
startups or small companies and yet on
the same time they claim these banks are
vital it just I just find it very
difficult to believe if we had an entity
like a bank which wouldn't take deposits
it would take investment Capital that
would be long term and you could not it
would throw that Capital at par and
those entities would then invest in
small businesses I cannot see why those
entities would do any worse job than
what we currently call it back and they
would not put the entire economy at risk
no you're so right about that because
one of the puzzles that we have in
finance in the empirical literature on
finance is how little debt particularly
these types of growth firms these young
enterprising firms how little that they
use and so are they really so dependent
on bank loans would we really not have
all that economic growth and all that
entrepreneurial activity without bank
loans probably we would still have the
exact same economic activity so we need
to have more evidence to support the
idea that without banks making these
Investments the economy would really
suffer and just to be clear we're not
advocating getting rid of what people
call relationship banking we could still
have entities that are in small towns
financing small firms it's just those
entities should not be financed with
deposits that you can withdraw at par
those entities should be financed just
like all other Financial risky
investment with long-term capital either
Equity or long-term debt that way match
the riskiness of the Investments with
the riskiness of how the Investments are
financed so we're not advocating to get
rid of the relationship banking system
we have we're advocating we have to get
rid of the way we Finance it because the
current way of financing it is basically
a huge subsidy for Bank Equity holders
and I would even say for Bankers
themselves because a large part of the
subsidy goes in Banker salaries to say
it even slightly differently we just
have to be upfront to investors all the
time what the risks are that they're
taking and so by people putting deposits
in Banks they are being misled because
you're being told that your deposits are
riskless while the Investments are risky
and the only way to make good on that
promise is by having an expensive
government insurance system in place
with a subsidy system in place without
that subsidy system people should be
much more aware that the Investments
that they have are risky and in fact
let's be clear even with the insurance
system having to go through your bank
Bank being shut down and you not being
able to access your deposits for a while
is not exactly a pleasant thing to go
through right no I mean I think the only
logical explanation why this obviously
better solution has not been adopted and
instead we have a solution where the
government bails out Banks is that it's
not in current Bankers interests current
Bankers live off those government
subsidies and because of that they're
greatly opposed to changing the system
to make AV economy more stable and be
less government ex taxpayers expenditure
so I think the time has come now to
basically end banking as we know it to
add one more point to that you could say
why isn't it just that we see new
entrants in the market because if banks
are so uncompetitive why aren't there
just new forms of financing that are
better able to do this but the point is
exactly is you made it if a particular
industry is heavily government
subsidized that's going to deter
entrance because it's almost impossible
able to compete with these old Banks
because they're so heavily government
subsidized and so without participating
in that same system in which you receive
the subsidy you can't really compete
with them and so that keeps that system
in place the competitive market can't
fix this exactly because the competitive
market has been distorted by the
government subsidy that is in place
well Jules up to now in discussing this
subject we've just basically stayed on a
pretty abstract level but I'm sure most
of our listeners are interested in
exactly what happened in the latest
backing grasses exactly what happened to
Silicon Valley Bank
so for that reason we've invited my
colleague Amit saru who's the Stephen
and Roberta Denning professor of Finance
at The Graduate School of Business at
Stanford to come on amid is an expert in
this area in fact he released a working
paper that had been working on for a
couple months on exactly the issues that
brought Silicon Valley Bank down Amit
welcome to the show
thanks for inviting me thanks a lot amid
it's great to have you so maybe it's
useful if you can explain a little bit
what in your impression has happened and
what the role of the increase in
interest rates that we've recently seen
has played in the fact that several
banks are now in trouble so as you all
know when Banks get their funds they get
their funds primarily from deposits who
are promised a low interest rate and the
funds that the banks take they invest in
long-term potentially illiquid
Securities or loans and because these
are long run they earn a higher interest
rate and the spread is what bank makes
and in normal times that spread is a
very high return on investment for
Equity holders which are a tiny part of
the liability side so that's how a
typical Bank works and all well and good
over the last few years as the interest
rates had gone down and a lot of
deposits have come into the bank the
question was what were the banks doing
in terms of Investments they had taken
positions in long-term Securities like
treasury asset-backed Securities and so
on largely because if you saw what was
happening to the yield curve which is
what they would get in these Investments
the yield was much higher for longer run
treasury is longer on rmbs asset-backed
Securities so the banks were hoping that
they get their deposits they pay them
let's say one percent and they are going
to put it in the long term supposedly
safe Securities and get a higher return
especially in the long run Securities
and that was all well and good till the
dying fed started raising the interest
rate because as many of us have noticed
inflation went up so at some point Fair
had to raise the interest rates and now
suddenly you saw a spike in the interest
rates and when the interest rates spiked
that clearly has an effect on the value
of the Securities and what it did was it
reduced the value of the Securities now
what is interesting in banking is that
even though that's the value of the
security that's Mark to market value
right if you had to take the security to
the market what would the value be the
value would go down but they don't have
to sell those Securities they only need
to sell those Securities if the folks
who gave their money ask for it right
now now remember these are the same
folks who are not asking for a high rate
and bank is probably giving them 0.5
percent or one percent think about your
own checking account how much are you
getting still 0.5 so
Banks were fine they were like yeah and
interest rates are going up but we don't
need to worry about this but interest
rates going up clearly depress the mark
to market value or the asset side and
then the question is is there going to
be an event which is going to force the
bank to take these Securities to the
market and as a result take a loss and
income Silicon Valley Bank where this
kind of event did happen so Silicon
Valley Bank had had a huge inflow of
deposits about I think the number if I
remember correctly is 140 billion
dollars had flown in in terms of
deposits over the last year and a half
and all of them were primarily in these
kinds of long-term Securities and
certainly as the startups who were
actually the ones who had actually
invested and given a bunch of deposits
to Silicon Valley Bank wanted to draw
down on their cash because they were
running out of cash if everybody's
noticed the economy has slowed down they
needed more funds to keep going and they
asked Silicon Valley Bank to basically
give them their deposits not because
they they were expecting higher rates
but just because they needed money that
event itself was enough to force Silicon
Valley Bank to liquidate some of these
Securities whose value had fallen once
that happened they had to come out and
say okay we have taken a loss on these
Securities that we have been now selling
and an aha moment happened where
everybody suddenly realized that oh
there is a bunch of these Securities
that banks have these Investments That
Bank have which actually are pretty
sensitive to interest rates and interest
rates have risen by three percent and it
interest rates right by three percent
anybody who's taken an Investments class
or even if they have not taken an
investment class you should know that if
interest rates go up by three percent
that's a huge change in the value your
value drops dramatically
so now what do we do we are left with
trying to persuade all the depositors
that yeah this is just a small blip
because we have enough money it's all
tied up in these long-term Securities
for five years or seven years and all
you need to do is just stay right if you
don't ask for money we are all good and
you know that statement is correct
because the Investments are in long-term
treasuries in long-term asset-backed
Securities but the one thing that we
have learned from Bank runs is that once
they start or once there is a doubt on
the solvency of the bank it's very
difficult to persuade the depositors
because everybody understands that if
they are not first in queue they might
be left holding hot potato in the end
and in this case the event was triggered
by the fact that Silicon Valley Bank had
this money coming in from Silicon Valley
which is a pretty tight-knit community
in the sense that Venture capitalists
all kind of know each other so there's
correlation in how their deposits behave
so they all come in together and they
all leave together and not only the
money coming from Venture capitalists
but also the portfolio companies that
they had invested in because they are
supposed to be advising them what to do
with their cash so you saw the news
where a lot of these Venture capitalists
went out and told their portfolio
companies that you need to be sort of
careful about this so the depositors
which are supposed to be sleepy that's
how we pay them point five percent
forever while the market rates might be
anything suddenly woke up and they woke
up because they were all connected and
once they woke up the bank now is forced
to sell even more Securities because
that's the only way they can pay it back
and you're now in a vicious circle where
all my long-term Investments is my
Silicon Valley Bank have to be
liquidated and if I have to liquidate
all of those assets I'm done because the
value of these Securities with the high
interest rates is really real Europe
part of what is so interesting about
your working paper is that when you
looked at Banks and you looked at their
solvency Silicon Valley Bank didn't look
that bad I mean they weren't good they
were like in the 90th percentile but
they weren't at an extreme yet they were
picked on and what you explained in the
paper is the relevant thing to look at
is not so much the solvency but the
fraction of deposits that are insured by
the FDIC in other words if I know my
deposit is under 250 I don't care I'll
get the money no matter what but if it's
over 250 I need to act and get it out of
there explain that to us so the key here
is are the depositors sleepy or not so
when do they wake up and if you look at
the banking system so the banking system
is 24 trillion dollars or used to be 24
trillion dollars I don't know what the
value is now slightly forward but right
24 trillion dollars and if you look at
the equity in the aggregate banking
system term it's like two trillion
dollars the rest is pretty much deposits
half of them are insured by FDIC half of
them are uninsured so these are large
deposits above 250 000 corporations
invest their money with the banks
Venture capitalists putting their money
portfolio companies or Venture
capitalists put in their money and you
know typically when we talk about
depositors being sleepy we lump all of
this together but let's remember 50
percent by value is not insured and now
when event occurs where bank takes a
huge loss because interest rates went up
and the point of the paper was to say we
can't assume that all of these
depositors are going to be sleepy
because in fact they are very active and
they are going to show up at the bank
way faster than those who think that
their deposits are still going to be
protected by FDIC and that would not be
a bad assumption because that's how
historically it's happened so you've got
to be very careful about what's the
proportion of uninsured depositors in
the depositor composition and Silicon
Valley Bank was at the extreme right so
you're exactly right if you looked at
the losses it was not in the extreme
yeah it had a reasonable set of losses
but a lot of banks were doing that there
were some Works Banks too but what it
was really extreme on was it had a bunch
of these uninsured depositors very high
97 percent of their depositors were
uninsured and they were all correlated
so if one woke up they woke up the whole
97 and in three days they had one third
of their deposits just leave which is a
very fast movement out of a bank and no
Bank can survive that so admit isn't
another way of interpreting your work as
saying the word sleepy is the wrong word
people don't move their deposits out of
Banks and they accept low interest rates
because there's a lot of transaction
costs and a lot of issues to move money
but it's not because they're asleep and
then if it stirs off they could actually
take big losses then those transaction
costs become very small and they are
very active when it comes to moving
money out isn't that one way of
interpreting your your work it is and
basically the paper you're referring to
says instead of just looking at Silicon
Valley Banks suppose you were to stress
test the whole banking system that's
what the paper has done and asked what
do you see in terms of how many banks
will be able to sustain such a run if it
does happen and how many banks would not
be able to so amid given all of that and
the stress tests that you just
introduced I'm somewhat surprised that
particularly since the financial crisis
in 2008 stress testing became something
that everybody was busy with and then at
the same time the FED Who's involved in
this is the one who is raising these
interest rates have these stress tests
missed out on the possibility of
correlated deposits incumbent Nation
with Rising interest rates leading to
this problem how could this be missed so
I think that's where the title of the
podcast that you have is very relevant
when we do these things we take all else
as being equal and it's not so my
preferred way of thinking about why this
might have happened is Regulators
whoever it might be and we are talking
about pretty sophisticated Regulators
they designed the stress test to address
a particular situation that had happened
in 0708 and we had different scenarios
pretty tough scenarios but we were going
to be looking at certain things like
default rates on loan portfolio and all
the kind of things that had happened in
the 0708 crisis fast forward and we went
to a regime of very low interest rates
and now are going to a regime of very
high interest rates the type of risk we
are talking about is very different we
are talking about an interest rate risk
that is not what happened in 0708 so if
I had to take a guess the stress test in
general will do a great job telling you
what the credit situation of the loan
portfolio would be and I still don't see
the defaults going up so that seems
reasonable but what they didn't do a
great job was to look at what would
happen to the other parts of the
portfolio which could actually be pretty
sensitive to the kind of things that are
happening in the micro economy and if
you don't understand the whole picture
or at all times that's the problem that
all else does not remain equal and even
very sophisticated actors and players
might miss out on the effects but don't
you think that we always miss out on the
next thing that happens exactly for that
reason are we not always risk managing
the last crisis and never managing the
crisis that's coming ahead of us so that
makes you wonder how useful this way of
approaching the problem is there is
always a debate about exact regulation
versus exposed regulation right so my
time having spent enough time thinking
about this in the banking spaces
Regulators have a role to play but I
think we cannot substitute something
like a huge amount of equity which is
another way of saying that you're moving
towards a narrow Bank maybe you want to
take risks go ahead but then you need to
internalize the costs you as in being
the bank so once you do that it becomes
easier because the actors taking the
risk are going to be internalizing
whatever is happening and Regulators
might do something on the margin but
they will not be the sole drivers of the
direction in which the banking or the
credit or the risk or how it's getting
allocated is going to be decided we are
going to let the market participants do
it and they can internalize the risk in
their own way definitely thank you very
much I made you really appreciate you
coming on the show excellent thank you
both for inviting and we'll put the
working paper in the show notes for
anybody who's interested in seeing it
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at Apple podcast we'd love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
Next Episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcast for more information and
episodes visit all else equalpodcast.com
or follow us on LinkedIn the oil sequel
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by University FM
[Music]
thank you